Again, this.
Hi, Mark, how are you?
I'm getting yourself. Happy Friday.
Doing well. Happy Friday.
So, yeah, it's Independence Day here in the Philippines.
Well, thanks for a good Friday, right?
Yeah. Can't complain. It's Friday.
So speaking of the holiday, we had a meeting this morning with the entire team and there was a miss, there was a miscommunication between myself and the ownership.
Mhm.
as far as allowing, you know, Jerome and Angela to kind of have today. So to keep that confusion from happening again, if you can send me just a kind of a list of holidays that you all observe, that way I can try and coordinate because what I would have liked to have done and what my plan was
Mmh.
Mhm.
Is to allow kind of 1 to have today, and then...
Day, so they both kind of got that long weekend, just maybe on the opposite sides.
Okay.
Mhm.
So I would like to try and be able to work some of that out.
For you know, for future, so if you can send me just a quick email that has some holidays that are observed, that way I can.
Look at our our schedule and and and have a more in-depth conversation with him, 'cause I...
I think he just kept misunderstanding what I was trying to say and he was on the road while we were having the conversation and I didn't, I don't think I got his full attention and it could have been handled a lot better.
Yeah.
Okay.
But we talked through all of that this morning, as well as the requested time all for next week.
Mhm.
As well, because I thought Jericho wanted Tuesday, Angela wanted Tuesday and Wednesday, and then actually another team member had requested Thursday and Friday. So I'm like, I'm looking, I've been pulled up holiday calendars. Like, what am I, what's going on next week, guys? Like, just everyone wants off like what's going on?
Yeah, me too.
Ohh.
Ohh, my God!
Okay.
Yeah.
So, we we can we talked about that, you know, this morning as well. So, it is Jericho's birthday on Tuesday.
That I didn't.
Yeah, I think it's not him, but his partner. I'm not sure, but yeah, he mentioned him. Yeah.
Okay, yeah, either I just, you know, celebrations, like, cool. But it's also another colleague's birthday that Friday. So like, okay, it's starting to make sense now. Angela, what are you doing? Like, what's going on with you? So hers is actually in July, like you said. So we were all kind of confused.
Ohh, really?
TA.
The.
Yeah.
And yeah, I've been over racking my brain looking at the schedule like, what's going on next week, guys? What am I? I want to hang out. I'm missing out. What's going on? So I think we finally got it hashed out this morning and everyone is approved and knows what days they're going to be here.
And I'll let him know that with Angela, it's actually July, not next week with everyone else. So we should be able to accommodate that. There's plenty of time. But I went ahead and let him know the change at night as well.
June, yeah.
Yep.
Okay, so just to clarify, for Jericho, it's already approved on the 16th of June.
It is approved, yes, the 16th is approved.
Okay, and then for Angela, just you need to, you know, rephrase or like elaborate that again to the owner for 16th July and 17th.
Yes.
Yes, to ownership. That is actually July, not next week. Yeah.
Not June. Yeah. Okay. And for me, I'll be sending you the list of the holidays or the upcoming holidays so that we can plan ahead in regards to that. Okay. All right. Anything else?
I appreciate that.
I think that's it. I think that's it.
Okay. All right. So I'm just going to share my screen. It's going to be quick. Just an update on what's happening on the previous week for Jerome. So feel free to cut me off if you have any questions. So this is for week one for June. So we're going to do this at least three months, 30, 60, 90 plan, just for us to make sure that
Hello.
all is well and Jerome is developing his skills in terms of technical abilities and also how to handle tickets or basically the last time you've talked, we've talked about it is in regards to his ticket management that he needs to update his tickets. So I need to have or I need to see that.
Ohh.
progress in regards to that. So every, almost every day now, I'm just checking on him just to be sure that he's practicing that kind of habit to make sure that his tickets are up to date.
Thank you.
All right. So check-ins, highlights, action tracker, performance, way forward and recap. So let's start with this one. Candace, so you mentioned that you've talked to the owner of the company. So is there anything that we need to know aside from the planned PTOs or any changes in terms of the process that you guys have?
or we need to implement here as well.
No, everything, we're just, we're making some, I don't even really want to say necessarily we're making changes as much as we're really diving into the best way of handling our policies and procedures as we are growing. And so we're just trying a couple of things out. And right now,
I.
Mm.
I'm having a little difficulty with another colleague, so it's best that we're kind of, we're just shifting some things around, but it's nothing that anyone needs to be concerned with or anything like that. It's just a little minor adjustments on our end.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, okay. All right. Thank you. All right. So highlights for last week. So as of observation, Jerome has been progressing well and he was able to adapt best practices by the help of Angela. So I'm seeing the developments and also I've asked Angela earlier,
Yeah.
before we conduct the service call, she said that she is confident to say that Jerome can handle tickets on his own now compared to the previous weeks that we have. And I think you can also vouch for that kind of statement that
Jerome is performing well now.
I can.
I can, absolutely.
Okay, thank you. So in regards to the utilization tracking, like I mentioned before, that I have advised Jericho to create an internal ticket under a specific company that will not bill any client. So I provided that information to Jericho and he's doing that after.
right after that day that we have a service call. So hopefully by next week, we can measure now the utilization that he's doing in terms of non-billable as well, aside from the real tickets that he's handling every day.
Correct.
Okay, so yeah, I just have one quick question, Candace, in regards to that utilization tracking, do you want me to implement that as well to Angela or just for Jerome for now?
Mhm.
If it helps on your end as well, then I'm perfectly fine with it. But I don't have to have it on this side with Angela. I think we just have a little bit more time with Jericho before we kind of get to that point. But with Angela, it's not
Okay.
Mhm.
Yeah.
It's not necessary on my end, but I'm very open to it if you would prefer to do that on your end.
Yeah, because from my perspective at the moment, since this is just the testing stage, maybe you can just try it with Jericho for us to, you know, compare the workload that he has in terms of non-billable versus the billable, so that we can compare. And then from there, once we have a steady...
Ohh.
Who?
metrics for that, maybe we can implement that as well to Angela because I know Angela has extra task that you mentioned before, like the offboarding and the onboarding for those kind of tickets. So I don't want to add more in terms of that. So maybe we can.
Yeah.
This is just a testing stage, so maybe we can try for now for Jericho, and then from there the rest will follow.
Yeah, I fully agree.
Okay. All right. So next one is this one, leave approval for Angela and Jericho for the action tracker. So the only thing that we need to wait for is for Angela's PTO request to be approved. But for Jericho, I'm just going to inform him to book in or block his schedule on that.
The.
day which is on the 16th so that you guys will know as well.
All right, so performance analysis. This analysis is for week one of June. So as you can see, Candace, the tickets that he worked on is 15 total tickets, and then nine that he was able to close. And he was able to meet the target of 80%. He got average resolution rate is 88.
Hello.
percent, which is a big progress from his end. So I think he's getting there in terms of the technical knowledge that Angela is giving her. And I've asked Jerome as well earlier, if how is it going or how's the knowledge that you are getting from your colleagues and also from Angela and she said, or he said,
It's doing great. And he has this confidence already on how he talk. Like, I know what to do in the future and I can figure out by myself. So I didn't hear that before. So it's a new statement from him, which is a good thing that he was able to voice it out.
Because you mentioned as well last time that he's quite...
Not that vocal in terms of how he feels or if there, if he has like concerns or feedback from other persons, but right now I think he's trying to get along with other people now and the confidence is there.
Yes.
I agree. Even today in our meeting, he was on camera. We at the end, we kind of each one of us go through ending week kind of updates, like what we've been working on, where we're at with it. And he was able to articulate well, kind of
the things he's been working on. So much to say that he had, we were having some issues with access, with him accessing some unified sites, and we were able to actively work in that moment and verify he was able to get access to move forward with some of the tickets he had been working. So I agree, he is being
Mm mm.
Mhm.
He's vocal more, and even to even today's meeting, you can see an obvious difference from last week.
Okay, that's a good development from Jericho. Yeah, thank you for that inputs. And way forward, Jericho will actively monitor alerts and incoming tickets and auto task to ensure all response time requirements are met in a timely manner. Because I think two days ago, I tried to
Yes.
Um...
observe the ticketing system that you guys have and there's some few tickets there that are needing action like alerts and few normal tickets, easy win tickets, but it seems like it's just sitting there. So I asked him earlier if you will be the ones gonna managing that or monitor those kind of.
priorities, are you willing to take the role or the responsibility? He said yes. So I'm going to try to observe if he will be able to do the things that I need from him, especially being proactive in terms of the tickets.
because my target for him is, you know, at least after a week more or two weeks from now, I want him to increase the ticket count that he has because right now it's 15, which is great, but I want to see him shine.
more like Angela, so that the experience will be there, the technical knowledge will be there as well, like the experience firsthand, so that he'll going to learn from those kind of tickets that he's quite new to. So yeah, it's going to be a testing stage again.
for those kind of tasks on being proactive in terms of handling or monitoring the new tickets on the board. So is it okay, Candice, for us to do that with Jerome? Because yeah, I'm just here for him to assist. And if you have, if he has like,
Yes.
concerns or doubts. I'm just going to inform him to approach me or Angela if he's in doubt in terms of the tickets that he's quite new to.
Again, I'm on board with that. I think that would be great.
Yeah, okay. And lastly, in auto task, I just want to ask, Candice, do you have or you guys have like the time frame for you to, you know, from auto task to connect wise or transitioning?
My goal is to start July 1st.
Oh, okay.
I would like to start in a with clean billing, right? So if I can end of month out of auto task for June, I would like to be able to have the entire month. So I'm not splitting it, you know, trying to pull from each side to make sure billing's correct. So my goal is July 1.
Mm.
Okay, but in terms of the target date, which is July 1, is your clients will be migrated to ConnectWise that time already or it's going to be start from scratch?
So our RMM was already ConnectWise, so the only thing that we're going to be moving over to is the actual PSA, so just the tickets themselves. So on July 1st, the only thing that we should have to do it, and I actually think we'll probably do it the Friday before, or I would need to look at whatever.
Okay, I did take a text.
Mhm.
that day is. So the last day of June, we would actually move the enabler, the API key over, and that would be the only thing that, so they would still email support at Ryan Creek. It would just be going to the PSA then as opposed to auto task.
Oh, okay. All right.
Yeah.
So hopefully it's going to be a smooth transition this coming July 1.
Let's hope. Let's hope. That is definitely the goal.
But, yeah, but expect there's a few glitches that we need that you guys need to work on, but hopefully it's not that big or not a big deal. It's just a small glitch, but yeah, OK.
Yes.
Yes, and we have another support email for the another side of the company that Angela and myself, we kind of worked through as a test to, so we should better understand the process of making sure that the API key is and how it's set up properly and how.
Mhm.
processes through. So, and that has been successful. So I have been somewhat working out of the PSA because they are not billed out of anything as far as what we're doing with the MSP clients. They're not billed that same way. So I've been able to kind of work their tickets and things in there. So I think we're going to be okay, but they'll definitely be.
a bit of a learning curve as well, especially for some other colleagues that all they've ever worked in is auto test. They have no frame of reference with ConnectWise, the PSA at least. So we'll see how it goes.
Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. But yeah, but on the brighter side, Connectwise is much more user-friendly compared to Autotask. It's very user-friendly and like you can just play around with it and you can learn from it without other people teaching you because it's very broad.
like on where to go, like service desk tab, all the things that you need is already there. So yeah, I think it's going to be easy in terms of the new users to use ConnectWise compared to Autotask.
Yes, I hope so. I hope so.
Yeah, let's hope for the best. Okay, so lastly, Build It Live. This is the last question that I have. So is someone on the organization we're going to attend the Build It Live this August?
Right, that's all we can do.
No, we will not be available this August, but it is something that we continue to talk about and would like to prepare for next year.
OK, alright.
next year's Build It Live, we would like to prepare for that. We have an IT Nation conference in November, and that's kind of where we've all set ourselves to be ready to go to. But I did bring this to everyone's attention, and we would like, this is on our list of things we want to see if we can make happen for next year.
Mhm.
Okay.
Yeah, okay. And then I just wanted to confirm, Candace, in regards to our QBR, which is on the 17th, 9 A.m. So you're good on that schedule?
Right.
We are.
Okay, I'm going to confirm that to Andrea because I told her yesterday about it and she mentioned that if it's possible that I can confirm it for the last time just to be sure. So yeah, I'll create a schedule for our QBR on the 17th 9 A.m.
That sounds great.
Okay. Yeah, and I apologize, Andrea is not here today because it's the holiday. So I'm the only one, I'm the only one here now as the team lead. So I'm the offering for the holiday. So hopefully by July 3rd, I'll be the ones going to be on holiday and they'll be the ones going to be here on July 3rd.
No worries.
Yeah.
Yes, yes, yes.
But...
Okay, so any questions, Candace, before we end this meeting?
Yeah.
No, I think all is good. We've had a pretty good week, all in all. So I think we're in a really good space, and I always appreciate your time.
Thanks.
Yeah, and thank you so much as well for attending this call and you do have a great weekend ahead.
You as well.
All right, bye-bye.
Goodbye.